en france la hausse des prix de
l'énergie cristallise les tensions
l'aide de 100 euros promise par le
gouvernement pour soulager le
portefeuille des français n'aura pas
suffi à apaiser la grogne populaire en
tout cas pas celle des gilets jaunes les
sons dans les rues de paris cet
après-midi mobilisation en cours d'un
cortège entre reporter à nadège
abderrazak on l'a rejoint à deux suites
bonjour à nadège alors quelle est
l'ambiance pour cette manifestation qui
touchera pas
[Applaudissements]
réécoutez l'ambiance amiral est un être
et s'estime très bruyante également la
manifestation elle touche à sa fin et
les manifestants sont arrivés et bien à
monter un peu atteindre lui sacré coeur
donc c'est une grande satisfaction pour
ces manifestants et qui est à dire dont
déambuler depuis la place félix à éboué
tout au long de l'après midi aujourd'hui
pour protester contre l' pris contre la
hausse du prix des énergies elle hausse
du prix du carburant alors on va en
parler avec famille la louche un qui est
l'une des figures est déchaîné jeune
faouzi vous êtes on s'envoie beaucoup de
sourires chez les manifestants vous êtes
satisfait d'avoir pu atteindre le sacré
coeur cette fois ci exactement je sais
pas pourquoi mais les forces de l'ordre
vraiment nous ont laissé passer sans
aucun problème contrairement à plusieurs
de fois où on nous en empêcher et en fin
de compte les gens ont répondu
favorablement il ya une belle
mobilisation
les gens se sont opposés aux décisions
de moment ils ont dénoncé la hausse des
carburants et voilà il s'indigne vrai
sur un laps de aides de l'état dès 100
euros qui dit que c'est pas avec 100
euros qui va nous faire taire et nous
empêcher de manifester notre
désapprobation à cette politique qui est
menée et qu'on a dénoncé depuis trois
ans 100 euros s'est essayé d'acheter
notre silence c'est une aumône qu'ils
arrêtent de nous taxer qu'ils arrêtent
de se gaver sur des produits de première
nécessité indispensable pour l'ensemble
des français on nous rackettent ans en
nous prenons toujours notre argent et on
se demande en derrière comment on
pourrait faire pour leur permettre de
diminuer un petit peu leur charge en
leur reversant notre argent alors c'est
un comble voilà et en même temps on est
contre la prolongation du pass
sanitaires et on est content moi aussi
l'obligation fascine vaccinale dieu qui
est promis et qui est déjà effective
pour l'espagnol n'en veut l'entendre est
peut-être derrière nous mais jérôme
andrieu
donnent de la voix pour motiver les
jeunes
derrière nous
[Musique]
ces affiches ici on voit rien ne toucher
ne touchez pas à nos anciens pourquoi
c'était important de ce marché ne veut
pas choquer ici parmi eux 10 sacré coeur
alors ici c'est un lieu populaire c'est
le lieu le plus élevé de paris il permet
une visibilité puisque les gouvernants
et les élus ne veulent pas entendre au
moins là aujourd'hui c'est visible et
c'est visible ça c'est important et en
même temps ça touche l'ensemble des
français l'ensemble de la population j
aimerais que les décisions soient prises
pour qu'enfin on puisse vivre dignement
et décemment et plutôt que de prendre
des mesures ou des décrets qui sont pas
adaptés pour la population et bat enfin
il nous écouter bon soit visible et
julie la politique de maquereaux
aujourd'hui personne n'en veut pression'
a qui veulent se présenter pour
reproduire la même chose on fera la même
chose vous trouverez devant nous on sera
dans la rue et aujourd'hui des trois ans
justifie exactement notre présence trois
ans après de ce qu'on dénonce rien n'a
changé tout a empiré merci à faouzi les
doucheurs n'ai pas répondu à nos
questions vous l'avez entendu un gros
sourire
lellouche qui est bien c'est satisfait
et promeut la reine des manifestants
présents ici d'avoir fait table cette
montée vers le sacré coeur au cours des
derniers mois justement des forces de
l'ordre empêchaient l'entrée aux
manifestants gars c'est déjà une petite
victoire pour les chemises jaunes qui
est bien sont surprises ont déjà prévu
de retourner manifester samedi prochain
merci à nos nageurs pour toutes ces
précisions et